the physics department at the University
of Liverpool is home to some of our
leading scientists and trains the ones
who lead in future within here we apply
electromagnetic fields a major project
here is developing new particle
accelerators to rival the likes of the
Large Hadron Collider in Geneva it like
many other big European collaborations
is funded Under The eu's Horizon program
but post-brexit talks on the funding
have stalled and a big part of the
project here has been taken away from
the UK unfortunately because of the UK
not being associated with the Horizon
Europe framework program we had to give
up that coordinator role and transfer
the project over to Italy for scientists
like Welsh the UK government's promised
to match funding if we end up leaving
the EU program will still undermine a
history of leading big science
collaborations science is international
it requires collaboration and
collaboration at least has been made
more difficult by the ongoing
discussions so I think moment there is a
real risk of UK scientists and
institutions losing out because of the
uncertainties that have been created
our research institutions are already
Suffering The Fallout from the funding
route with Europe and that could go on
to impact other parts of the economy now
the last prime minister said he was
committed to making Britain's science
superpower what scientists and Engineers
want to know now is do the new
leadership share that commitment
observers worry a looming crisis in UK
science is being neglected at the
expense of other political priorities
the worst case scenario I think we will
see a brain drain of our brightest
talents going overseas I think we will
see more of our our best you know
technology-based companies finding that
it's easier to get their their scale up
funding overseas we need to be seen as a
great partner because really outstanding
science is not something that one
country does on its own the uncertainty
is proving toxic so far 22 uk-based
researchers who'd won direct grants have
decided to leave the country one from
the prestigious Crick Institute in
London leading a research project on
malaria I have no beef with the UK I
mean the UK offered me a significant and
really good opportunity I made a
decision I'm going to move away and of
course I will take people some of the
people with me and I will attract people
into the other country and I think
while short-term the impact might not be
so massive I think in the future there's
less people who are willing and wanting
to build a career in the UK in a
statement the government Department
responsible for science told us its
preference is to remain within the
Horizon program and blames the EU for
not honoring commitments made previously
but as scientists see it the longer the
impasse continues the greater the damage
to the UK's research reputation Tom
Clark Sky News